everything is pushed or pulled through
something
by something all that is and isn't
created and moved by some substrate
force
evolving from this to that towards
apparent nothing for apparently no
reason
other than itself what is this movement
what is our role within it
and can we integrate more seamlessly
into it
the ancient chinese philosophy known as
taoism is one of the primary schools of
thought that emerged and sustained
out of a volatile but intellectually
enriched period of chinese history
between around 700 and 200 bc
its origins long-standing popularity and
viewpoints
are often similar and discussed in
relation to other leading eastern
philosophies
like buddhism and confucianism by more
or less coincidence
taoism can also be said to contain many
similar ideas to the ancient greek and
roman philosophy
of stoicism it is generally accepted
that taoism was founded by the writer
and philosopher
known as lao tzu who is credited with
authoring the foundational taoist text
entitled the dao te ching however there
is no substantiated proof that lao tzu
ever actually existed and some
historians believe that the name could
merely be
a pseudonym of sorts either
intentionally or unintentionally
creating a legend-like figure for the
school this however
is also unproven if laotzu was real he
is believed to have been a record keeper
in the court of zoo in around 5th
century bc
china at some point during his later
life the story goes that lautsu grew
tired of the increasing bureaucracy and
corruption of zoo
and decided to leave on his way out the
border official recognized lao tzu
and knowing of his reputation of wisdom
asked if he would write down his
insights prior to leaving
allegedly laotsu did and this would
become the daotei ching
the most translated philosophical or
religious book in all of history
after the bible there are like most
things of this sort
different forms and sects of taoism that
implicate different ways of interpreting
behaving and thinking as a result of its
inherently vague and somewhat open-ended
nature
a division of philosophical religious
and political interpretations
have formed and fragmented over time and
thus
taoism has been rendered into somewhat
of a broad malleable philosophy
what is generally considered taoism
today specifically in the modern west
naturally deviates at least to some
extent from the likely origins
and initial interpretations separated by
upwards of 2500 years of time
and a globe of space this is to be
expected arguably
but it is no less worth noting and
respecting ironically though
the possible fluctuation and evolution
of taoism is perhaps a testament to one
of its own primary ideas
central to taoism everything is in a
continual state of flux
ceaselessly changing and adapting thus
no single idea or thing is to be
attached to
nothing is to be forced in or out of
place all is to be permitted to go its
natural course
subject to the one constant unchanging
truth that everything changes
and so it is perhaps nothing but a
confirmation of this idea
that the interpretation of taoism's
ideas in some sense
change over time to understand the
philosophical basis of taoist ideas it
is essential to know of the concept
known as the tao
the tao generally translates into the
way which in the context of taoism
refers to the natural way or order of
the universe
although the tao is so to speak more of
a blanket
abstract term for what is beyond human
concept and comprehension
the sort of force or substrate that
creates and propels
all things for apparently no reason the
incomprehensible origins and destination
of the universe
where logic and human sensibility
collapse a sort of god without a god
a creation without a creator the
infinite and the nothing in a singular
unified eternal dance with itself
for itself however according to lao tzu
even here this sort of explanation still
misses the point
and essence of the tao the tao that can
be told is not the eternal dao
the name that can be named is not the
eternal name
the unnamable is the eternal real laotzu
writes in the opening lines
of the dao tae ching the dao
is or at least appears paradoxical in
this sense by virtue of it being a word
that is spoken
and a concept that is in a roundabout
way understood
and yet it declares itself beyond
concept and states that it cannot be
stated
however perhaps sometimes words and
concepts of this form can work like
fingers
pointing in the direction of a thing
that can only truly be seen and
understood by living it essential to
taoism
is living according to this tao which is
to say living in accordance with nature
lao tzu suggests one can accomplish this
by accepting the fluctuation of
everything and giving up rigid judgments
attachments
expectations and controlling efforts in
life in doing so
one becomes more closely intertwined
with the natural order of things
taking on a sort of fluid intuitive and
harmonious relationship with the natural
world
perhaps one of taoism's most useful and
slightly more practical ideas
that stems from this is the concept of
wu wei
which generally translates into
non-doing or effortless action
this idea does not literally suggest
doing nothing or doing things that are
easy per se
but rather suggests cultivating
abilities circumstances
and lifestyles in which one frequently
becomes fully immersed in their actions
so much so that they are almost carried
by action rather than the other
way around in other words engaging in
tasks with a deep focus and presence
surrendering to more spontaneous second
nature instincts
like how a bowl's emptiness allows for
it to be filled and made useful
for lao tzu emptying or stilling the
mind
allows being to unfold more effectively
in many respects this idea of wu way
parallels modern day positive
psychology's notion
of the flow state they differ of course
in the latter being underpinned by
science
and the former by more spiritualized
philosophy but at bottom
both seem to point to the same relative
idea a state where one experiences a
deep focus
satisfaction natural efficiency and
absence of self-consciousness
one might experience this state when
they are in the thralls of a creative
flurry
and a work of art seems to almost create
itself or a moment in a sport where one
seems to almost know exactly what to do
two moves ahead without ever stopping
and thinking
or when one comes up with an idea or the
right thing to say
more easily once they stop trying or
perhaps the more general gut instincts
and
intuitions felt in everyday life that
seem to just feel right for no other
reason
and are for lao tzu perhaps life more
broadly
is to be lived in this zone like how the
breath breathes
the heart beats the birds fly the fish
migrate the wind blows
the earth spins all perfectly on their
own the taoists believe life operates
most functionally
when simplified to its more intuitive
natural intelligence
like water is humble and soft yet erodes
the sides of mountains
and dissolves rocks by quietly patiently
and persistently flowing its natural
course so too should the human act
to work and live with a sort of softness
and almost passivity to the universe
observing the flux of everything around
us and gracefully adapting to it
as it does can you coax your mind from
its wandering and keep to the original
oneness
can you cleanse your inner vision until
you see nothing but the light
can you love people and lead them
without imposing your will
can you deal with the most vital matters
by letting events take their course
can you step back from your own mind and
thus understand
all things this is the supreme virtue
lao tzu writes we are drawn to the
graceful yet indifferent quality of
nature when we see someone forcing
something be it an artistic performance
or a performance of self in everyday
ordinary life
we almost always know and we almost
always dislike it
we say that it doesn't feel natural that
it feels forced that someone is being
fake
we have a seeming innate sensitivity to
what is tried rather than simply done
ultimately we want truth we want honesty
we want the natural motion of everything
something or essence that cannot be
explained by anything else other than
the act of doing or experiencing it
words and ideas of intellect seem to
fall short to the apparent
deeper truth that is revealed by this
authentic poetry in motion
realistically this notion of not trying
and relinquishing conscious effort
is perhaps practical and effective in
cases of artistic
athletic and certain social
circumstances however in the broader
application of the idea it isn't obvious
how much one really should or even can
let go and accept the way things are
can the can of worms of
intellectualization force
and desire truly be closed once it's
already been opened
moreover is it not possible that
conscious effort
forcefulness and opposing action with
the apparent natural world
are all in fact natural parts of the
natural world
in the context of taoism could working
against the dao
merely be the dao working against the
dao for the sake of its perpetuation
perhaps a further step in the logical
path of taoism and philosophies like it
involves an even greater surrender that
doesn't even permit one to choose or
consider if they are surrendering or not
rather one is born into the surrender if
in taoism the relationship of all things
is a cooperative unified whole even when
things appear in conflict
is not human and nature always in
cooperation
even when they seem to oppose each other
if darkness creates light
silence creates sound beauty creates
ugliness
good creates bad does not forcefulness
create non-forcefulness
does not man create nature does not
consciousness
create unconsciousness human is part and
parcel of nature
and so how could human act in any other
way
how could man-made material or action
ever not be natural
of course this is just one counter idea
that stems from just one
interpretation of an elusive mysterious
taoist idea
and to step back on it a little there is
no question that our conscious
observations and logic
do often fool us and we are in many
cases
clearly deviating from what's best when
we force or strive for what we think is
a drunk person who does not resist or
fight what is happening
often receives significantly less injury
when falling or in a car crash
compared to those who tense up and
consciously brace
resist and try to save themselves and so
clearly there are better ways for things
to go
plenty of which would go better if we
never got involved
perhaps the only remaining questions are
when should we and when
shouldn't we and how does one find out
without screwing the whole thing up
perhaps these questions miss the point
perhaps the point
ignores these questions of course
like all ideals of philosophy or
religion taoism's concepts are likely
just that
ideals ideals that are not without some
level of contradiction
or general incompleteness on their own
but regardless of this
and the potential limits of its
applicability the concept suggested by
taoism are nonetheless filled with rich
insights that provide worthy
useful counterweights to the more common
brutish way
of mind and culture the thinking that
things must always be a different way
or must go one's own way for it to be
the right way that there must always be
some better ideal around the corner
that isn't or couldn't be in this moment
right now
that one needs to seek or strive for
what they already have
and know
[Music]
so
you